Oh what is going on YouTube now I've
been driving a car for a while now and
as soon as we get older we tend to be
like that there are a lot of shitty ass
drivers out there let me rephrase that
some of you mother y'all can't drive now
I'm not saying I'm a great driver at
best I'm an OK driver but someone you
cross-eyed camel dick faces out there
have no idea what road rules are and I'm
gonna help y'all out with that one so
y'all ready know what it is
LG awesome baby let's get it let's go
use your [ __ ] turn signal look
you let me fish let me ask you something
how the hell was I supposed to know that
joke dumbass was gonna turn left at
McDonald's hmm
well I guess I should have figured it
out with your big ass was flatten the
tires on your driver's side seat you
filthy McNasty what am I supposed to do
read your mind predict the future you
useless sack of magical beans do I
[ __ ] look like a Korean Miss Cleo oh
she gonna turn a left now oh oh
accordian Carter say yeah what you don't
want to use your signals cuz you think
it's useless [ __ ] I hope somebody
friends into the back of your car sir
yes smack it ugly-ass face on the
steering wheel yeah cockeyed mooks
knuckle you what how come nobody
switches lanes at the appropriate time
hmm every time somebody's trying to get
to the left from the far right they do
it right at the turn signal you have
single-handedly and dangering the lives
of everybody in the Greater Los Angeles
area every time this happens up ray that
it's not an Asian person but without
fail you'll be an Asian person please
don't be an Asian person by what the
hell lucky in the lady mother [ __ ] my
Asian brothers and sisters this is not
Asia we have something called road rules
if you run over somebody it's not their
fault they got in the way of your car
attached to your doors or sideview
mirrors use it those lines on the road
tell you where you're supposed to be
you're mad why do some of the worst
drivers spend the most money on their
cars why the hell would you spend so
much money on something that you have no
idea how to use that's like my shape man
buying a set of weights and saying okay
what is for like a sex machine or
something but I swear if I see another
Asian dude with a supercar that doesn't
know how to drive it I was
Asha's pinkie toe with a break [ __ ]
how big can your spoiler be on your car
do you think it makes your car faster
hey do you see my spoiler and a 5 volt
power I hate it when somebody else [ __ ]
up but they give you the finger how
you've only mad at someone else after
you just try to murder them with a
two-ton vehicle where the hell are you
going that you want such a hurry that
you have to run me off the road hmm
don't you hate it when somebody tries to
kill you and you can't get mad at them
cuz they apologize to you and [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] oh god mother you apologize god
damn I can't get mad now
feels like a helping to sneeze you know
what now that I think about it why does
this offending I don't get it who the
[ __ ] was the person that decided that
this meant [ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ] no this
you know what this one was better I like
this one here we go people just learn
how to drive before you get a car with
fancy heated seats and 5000 horse powers
learn how to use your vehicle cuz one
day you might meet my awkward ass on the
road and I will flip the [ __ ] out you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna give
you the beat that's right it's more
offensive because it's the shortest
finger on your hand means go kill
yourself
feel good right all right yeah money in
my pocket rocket money on flower flow i
letter with Joe
oh yeah look at that boy go